et intervenant lors de cette session
plénière le président du conseil mondial
de l'énergie jean marie dauger s'est
exprimé un autre micro confiance
transparence et coopération sont
essentiels à tous les niveaux
déclare-t-il dans cette période de
transition quand l'écoutent le
changement climatique mais aussi de
façon générale la pensionnaire gtx
réduit les transformations dans la
structure de la demande
et le mouvement est très engagé on croit
mon projet car pour 10 et égard données
économiques et ce sera ceci conduit à
s'éloigner des sons énergies les plus
polluantes quand on peut le faire étendu
évidemment un homme entraîné des
tensions qui sont la zapa point de vue
mondial il est essentiel que dans cette
ère de transition et nous sommes entrés
dans une phase de transition majeure
dans le domaine de l'énergie notamment
mes mains les deux semaines de ce site
et en plus elle semble que général il
est absolument essentiel une bonne
coopération luthiste à tous les niveaux
entre le gouvernement les opérateurs
entre les opérateurs et leurs clients
c'était et que tous mt de coopération
c'est razak bad confiance et de et de
transparence qui permettent d'établir
à chacun de devenir sa politique au en
fonction de ses priorités